[Music]
hey
everybody what's up everybody it's
sunday yep got everybody's here mango's
here
we got a [ __ ] con of botzlon con of
otsulon
is the ultimate ricardo monteblanc
[Laughter]
didn't know that right he's not like
undercover today no he's not he's not on
the cover he doesn't have to be so he
must not be like worried that he's going
to get into trouble
the ultimate ricardo montablanc
anyway this is a good movie man blood
vessel we saw it last night
it's [ __ ] it's good i thought i couldn't
figure out what it was about
they were on a nazi ship yeah and it was
a ghost ship
yeah everybody was gone pretty much
already everybody was dead and gone on
on the thing and there was all this
weird traces of something that happened
i thought maybe it might have been some
kind of a bio weapon that got out
but the plot thickens
[Laughter]
find all these corpses and stuff they're
all black veins on them they're
mushed up and [ __ ] up looking they
find a little girl on the boat
she's wearing a gas mask and i'm like
yeah they got a bio weapon [ __ ]
on board or something i thought it was
something like the thing
and i did like the movie it's like a
mixture of alien
the thing what else there was um
i've seen some other reviewers compare
it to uh
death [ __ ] or ghost ship um and virus if
you guys even though that movie wasn't
very good
but it's kind of like that where it's um
so it's basically it's set
at the you know in the last days of
world war ii
you have like a lifeboat full of people
there's like there's
and they're all like different uh
nationalities like there's like an
english nurse there's like a
like another english guy who's like some
kind of pencil pusher or something
there's an australian dude there's a
russian sniper there's all they were on
like a hospital transport
and it got torpedoed yeah and so they
were the only
survivors so they're kind of like out in
the middle of the ocean and then they
see
a german i think it's a minesweeper like
the ship or whatever and so
they they can't see that there's nobody
on there
um but they're just like look we can't
we gotta get on here we're gonna [ __ ]
diet or in the middle of the oceans they
climb into the ship and then see that
everybody's gone and then they start
finding corpses all over the place yeah
corpses everywhere they can't figure out
what the [ __ ] happened they fire [ __ ]
weird symbols and books uh looks kind of
like a damn
like a [ __ ] not german eagle with a
weird serpentine looking symbol
underneath it they had that on a couple
little things they had
all this fabled nazi gold was on it
yeah all this stolen treasure yeah like
all the artwork and stuff i was like a
nice touch yeah they knew that that was
on the ship
and uh they come across this little girl
she's wearing a gas mask and she speaks
this weird language
i thought it was latin but i was wrong
no it's some kind the russian guy said
he recognized it and it was some kind of
an archaic russian
right yeah i think that was the
implication sure something from
something from maybe the 1400s or the
1300s
and she keeps saying the word uh family
family
familia and she's trying to take him
down the down in the bottom of the ship
you know
and they go oh man she's trying to show
us her family
and when she takes them down there i
don't know should we spoil this [ __ ] i
guess we got to talk about the movie huh
i mean i already said well because like
i said i didn't know
i mean i had i had an assumption because
of what it's called yes some of the
stuff happened
she shows them these badass sarcophagi
these big [ __ ] coffins and they're
just or ornately [ __ ]
decorated they're huge the the nazis had
them all wrapped up
uh they and they had one that was for a
man and another one that was for a woman
and you're assuming that the little girl
came out of the damn one for the child
and she's pointing at him and amelia
and it's just all this satanic damn
weird-ass carvings on them you know
and uh i can't remember exactly what
happened so they got her out of there
one there was a nazi survivor on the
ship yeah and he tries to kill the
little girl he tries to warn him it's
kind of like the
kind of like the scene out of the thing
with the dog yeah yeah dog right
it was kind of like that yeah he's
trying to kill the
girl and he's trying to warn him but
they don't none of them speak german i
mean the australians speak the
australian speaks a little bit of german
because he was a pow but he doesn't
understand what the guy is saying
right and one and then later on the
russian guy goes down there and he tries
to
break the seal on that big coffin
because he wants to steal [ __ ] you know
like a russian does the russian gun
steal
i thought that i thought the english guy
did that oh no i guess not no one no it
was the american was it the american guy
the american don't matter russian
american americans [ __ ] stole [ __ ]
during world war
ii my unit the [ __ ] 506 [ __ ] stole
germany blind just robbed it blind
yeah the guy from the 506 and you know
the movie banded brothers
stole all kinds of hitler's [ __ ] his
personal scrap book and everything
i don't think anyone's gonna feel bad
about it he's still got it he's up on it
he stole it from the eagles nest
there's all kinds of stuff my uni i mean
you know tournaments fair play other
dudes know where it is
but the thing is it's a it's a relic
yeah it was hitler's [ __ ] personal
scrapbook they know who's got it they're
just waiting for him to die
he's probably dead by now they may have
gotten him back but oh speaking of death
did you hear that alex trebek died today
oh okay wow isn't that a bummer yeah was
that pep uh
prices right no not prices jeopardy
jeopardy that's right he was 80 i think
or he's
in the 80s and i he didn't retire either
i think he was still on jeopardy until
like the last [ __ ] second
anyway dude bust the coffin open man and
there's just this [ __ ] ugliest thing
you could
goddamn imagine it looks it it looks
like a nosferatube of the huge
bat head and it [ __ ] comes out and it
turns out
you're going this is a [ __ ] vampire
and
uh it's not though it's considered
sort of like a vampire it's better than
a vampire it's a stragoi it's a string
which is a [ __ ] archaic russian
vampire
when you have vampires and mixed that
[ __ ] with russians
a russian vampire you know [ __ ] it's
gonna be
and and it's gothic it's gotta be from
the [ __ ] 1300s or 1400s
because it looked like it was
elizabethan what did you say
around that era 13 is something kind of
like from the time of uh
uh uh [ __ ] countess bathory or
something based on the architecture and
everything
but this thing's [ __ ] badass man it's
big
yeah i mean like the the makeup and [ __ ]
like that is really good in this yeah i
mean it looks like
it pretty much all looks like practical
effects yeah it's like all practical i
think it's all miniatures and all like
just makeup work yeah and when it
talks it's just got this super sinister
russian voice that comes out of it and
it's just like this archaic russian
and the subtitles are in english are in
an ancient
font that follows they're [ __ ] i love
that yeah the font so
because it's because it's got a real
strong accent i was so delighted
yeah it's got like a font from the
[ __ ] 1300s and [ __ ]
and uh but not it's not cheesy in any
way which is cool
you buy into it you're like okay and
it's saying cool [ __ ]
and it's got different abilities than a
vampire
i mean i guess vampires like dracula and
stuff like that sort of have
yeah the kind of abilities that this one
has like it's sort of it's not like out
of left fielder it's more
witch-like in a way it's like a witch
and a vampire and a bat
yeah and it's not a shape shifter but it
can
the female one can appear as anything
yeah they can do like
glamors yeah mickey hallucinate
yeah because she can yeah i don't know
like can the male one do that
it didn't seem to have to i don't
remember if the male one did that enough
but the female one day he was just
aggressive
yeah and i don't know if we should spoil
some of the [ __ ] and the little girl
could do it too
yeah a little girl the little girl had
some abilities and she the thing is
the little girl looked human so i guess
they grow
into looking like so looking like an
bat-headed
monster and they had been asleep in
there for [ __ ] centuries
yeah it was it was pretty [ __ ] they
were some of i don't even know
like i don't know if the implication was
that the nazis knew what the
knew what those were or if they just
were like ooh pretty boxes and they just
like took
everything and they didn't know that
there was vampires in there well they
probably weren't qualified to open up
coffins because you know [ __ ] would
disintegrate right yeah it looked like
they had just sealed it yeah so you
couldn't open it they're probably gonna
open it back in germany
yeah but that's what i would have done
surprise [ __ ] well
as soon as that dude opened it it just
[ __ ] came up out of there like it was
[ __ ] fine and bit him
yeah but yeah it's like i really really
did like this movie i feel like
i can't believe that no one up to now
well maybe i could be wrong about this
but i can't believe that no one up to
now has not made
like a vampires on a boat movie that was
called blood vessel
i mean it seems so it's it's right there
yeah and this is
as far as i know that's the first person
that's on it crazy yeah but it was a
good story
very good edit good script everything
about it was really good to give it five
stars and it was a shutter exclusive
wouldn't it
yeah it actually i think it came out
last year like at some festivals
um but it didn't get like a wide release
or anything like that but it kind of got
some buzz about it so shutter ended up
picking it up
had a good fast pace to it it didn't it
didn't have any unnecessary dialogue
um got to the point uh had a real good
monsters
the monsters were characters they had
personalities that [ __ ] [ __ ] worked
good
just it looked cool i liked the i liked
the look of the movie too
just the whole um because it's all set
at night like it's during one night i
guess
and um so you're like it's just the
inside of this ship and then it's just
kind of every now and then there's this
red flood of light
yeah you know what i mean so it's very
very red and black and like with
deep blues and stuff it's like really
really nice looking yeah and i liked
what the struggle the straggler
what they could do their abilities yeah
i mean it's vampire-like but also kind
of witch-like
yeah because because doing a glamour
that's a very witch thing
yeah that's why i kind of thought mind
control it's like a
mixture of [ __ ] weird weird
biological abilities involving biting
people
uh making people hallucinate mind
control type stuff
it's hard to tell some of it seemed like
it was a
either some kind of an innate ability or
maybe some kind of sorcery it might have
been a source or two it's hard to tell
yeah it's just it but it's definitely
like a like a vampire it looked like
nosferatu from the oh but imagine if
nosferatu looked a lot more like a damn
vampire bat
yeah that same face yeah that had like
the nose and the bigger
big [ __ ] ears and [ __ ] yeah it was it
was super cool looking i thought yeah
they found a bunch of satanic damn books
or books warning about it
that was with the coffin it was pretty
cool pretty cool
had a crucifix that was hidden inside
the book
oh yeah i liked that remember that yeah
you had that big crucifix and stuff
there just had
a lot of nice touches and it did things
to people's crucifixes
remember that yeah yeah yeah it's like
i really really liked this movie it's
like it took me like a couple minutes
because when it um first starts it just
starts with them in the
life raft and they just kind of like
establish and then like they're on only
on the life raft for a couple of minutes
and then like they see the ship and they
get on it
and you know there's a lot of you know i
there is like a lot of like character
development like between them like
talking to each other and establishing
the characters and stuff while they're
looking around the ship like not
necessarily knowing what's going on
and then like finding the bodies and
stuff so you know it takes a while
before you get to the monsters but
that's
just like yeah that's what they do like
with all like even an alien and stuff
like that
it was a long time before you saw the
alien and kind of like in salem's lot it
and in other vampire movies i wouldn't
say it makes
it kind of makes zombies it's hard to
tell if it's zombies or if they're like
junior vampires or both
yeah they're they're it makes the living
dead i think
a lot of crossovers a lot of crossover
type stuff which i kind of like that
take on it that way
i did it too things are not so clear-cut
they're kind of covering
both mythos it's like it's a vampire
that kind of makes
zombies that are kind of like vampires
it's all just living dead stuff
it's like psychic abilities but it's
also kind of like magic
and it's also kind of like something
having to do with biology and biting and
like
your blood being impurified and there
was
some good and evil type religious motifs
going on with [ __ ] crucifixes and
stuff so you know
and the way and it was in the damn state
satanic looking coffins
and it was saying stuff you know if i
remember correctly
didn't it say something about his gods
and their gods and or what was it there
was a religion oh yeah he was actually
saying something about that wasn't he
now i can't remember what it was i
remember correctly so i think we didn't
watch it last night we watched it the
night before last night
i got to go back and see it again
something about his people
and our people and his gods and our gods
and his gods
it was kind i'd like to see it again
some of it went by a little too fast
and the font it's it's not difficult to
read it's just
it kind of kind of kind of lost me in
some of the some of the fonts and what
you know
yeah i mean i kind of wanted to
i actually wouldn't mind watching it
again with the um closed captioning on
because i think i missed some
conversations yeah because my [ __ ]
hearing is bad
so i might have missed like a few things
that they said
but yeah i definitely want to watch it
again with like the closed captioning on
so i can get more of like the sense of
character and stuff
but it's like i it's just cool because
it's kind of like yeah it's vampires but
they went like a different way with it
and
you know russian vampires yeah and it's
just coming in it's good going is it
this is about spiritual warfare
uh kinda kinda yeah they don't go super
into that i don't think
it's it's it's a russian vampire called
a
stragoi and it's it's it's a russian
vampire
yeah and it's like probably from the
1300s yeah
it's badass it it's weird it can i don't
know when you jumped in the conversation
i'm just seeing you now
it does things that a witch does it does
things that a vampire does it kind of
makes
zombies and the zombies are kind of like
a cross between a red field and another
vampire
it's very gray area yeah but somebody
said like a thrall
like a thrall yeah but they look
infected
yeah and he can possess them that's the
[ __ ] weird thing
it would i didn't want to spoil it but i
got to because he asked the question
once he bites you after a while once
that infection comes in he can go into
your body and take it over
and talk to you and he can see through
he runs he can run you on remote control
yeah that's basically which it looks
like spiritual possession
yeah yeah like and uh but they're also
kind of like a zombie
yeah some of them remember some of them
were just like walking corpses
yeah that he controls yeah so i guess
they do die but they're the living dead
yeah i'm that's what i got because like
like i said they did like some of the
people that got
you know that got killed that were like
of the main cast like they were still
walking around like a normal person but
then like every now and then
you know they get possessed but like i
said that's not
crazy like out there for vampire
abilities because dracula could kind of
do that too
yeah yeah it's just a slightly different
it's a slightly different
um enunciation of it if you're talking
about that'd be a good way to put it
yeah it would be like it kind of struck
me as as like
i could buy into that like if i ran into
that and it started doing that
oh this is what zom this is what the
vampire legends are about this is the
same thing
yeah that's how i would interpret it
yeah it's real close
but different it was big too
uh you know the guy was probably had
[ __ ] stilts on
i would think it was probably about
seven feet tall maybe it seemed like
a quite a bit taller yeah big and
[ __ ] strong and his
his wife was with him who was kind of a
i guess a cute version of that
oh she wouldn't she was hot as a vampire
yeah but she was like
she looked like a rat though a lot of or
another bat
she didn't like humans to other vampires
that's like super foxy yeah she's foxy
funny ass [ __ ] vampire bat nose or a
rat nose on her big [ __ ] ears and
um big long fingers and
um they knew what they were and they
just ate people
yeah yeah the daughter looked pretty
time
the daughter was cute she was probably
what six
maybe a little older yeah it looked
totally human but it wasn't
i got a little bit of uh from her i got
a little bit of the uh let the right one
in
vibe yeah that one because i don't think
you saw that maybe that was like a movie
about a little girl that was a vampire
yeah and like made friends because she
was like boy next door but yeah
so i guess they kind of as they age they
get they turn into those
and they were you know centuries old and
it was just [ __ ] excellent movies
yeah i really liked it like i said
really um
i liked it much more than i was
expecting to like i said it had like uh
high ratings on shutter
which are usually pretty accurate um
you know i think it was four skulls four
out of five skulls yeah um
so like yeah like i said the look of it
like the concept of it was really cool
like i liked
um i guess that it was directed by
justin dicks might have been
uh might have been written by him as
well i
i'm not sure i think that he might be
like a special effects guy i'm not real
sure
this is kind of gory it's not like
over-the-top gory but it does have some
good gore in it and it looks like most
of the stuff is like practical
wasn't it romanian it might have been
romantic it might have been a baby now
that you mentioned it yeah
we see here's the weird thing because
she didn't say that many words
remember when i said i can understand it
it sounds like portuguese right
romanian and portuguese are very close
so that's probably what it
what it probably was romanian and um
i don't know i thought we had somebody
in the uh in
in the just in the chat that had seen it
yeah tammy saw it tammy what do you
think about it tammy yeah tammy said she
really liked it yeah
i really liked it too i thought it was
really cool it's like the thing
alien and a vampire movie a weird
vampire movie all put together
um you could tell it's mid-budget but
that's great because
yeah nothing wrong with that they didn't
do any cg that i saw
yeah if it was cg i couldn't tell it was
cg it's all practical effects and
miniatures
because the ships in certain shots the
ship is a miniature
but it looks good looks a lot better
yeah cause it's actually there yeah
instead of like a cartoon costumes were
good cass was good acting was pretty
good
acting on the monsters was great um i
really did like those ones yes
the subtitles when the monster spoke
with the font and the dudes
and the the the vampire's voice or the
what's it called a stragoy
their voices were good yeah i bought it
yeah they were creepy
yeah but yeah i was gonna say too that
um
the same day that shutter added this
movie they also added salem's lot
yeah that's if you guys haven't seen
salem's lot see it it was maybe they
take
they tend to like they tend to put like
if they put one vampire movie they tend
to put like a handful of vampire movies
like oh they're
all like all the same stuff like an old
one a new one like you know what i mean
so i think that's kind of cool salem's
lot was one of the first vampire movies
i had seen as a kid that because it was
a made for tv movie yeah but it's a real
good one
yeah especially for a stephen king movie
because a lot of stephen king movies
kind of were not that good
or iffy yeah but it was a very good made
for tv movie i don't know
how many hours they trimmed it down to i
think
the tv version is like four hours i
think i think it's four hours yeah
because i think it was
it was originally broadcast over two
nights i want to say
two or three i think we have it on
blu-ray or
dvd or something but yeah cause we
watched it not too long ago but i just
noticed that shutter had added it
um tila asked do you guys have a
favorite vampire movie
probably interviewed a vampire the whole
looker i like to interview with the
vampire the hunger that's my favorite
one
i mean there's a lot of good ones
there's a lot of good ones here near
dark is good too we need to like review
that one one of these days
but uh yeah so um i like to interview
because the
just just because the story i didn't
like i didn't like queen of the damned i
thought it
was nobody liked it it wasn't up to
snuff uh i had
i've read the vampire books from anne
rice yeah
nah it would have been better had they
done vampire lestat
yeah i don't know why they just didn't
do the [ __ ] trilogy i'm like
it's three books why are you trying to
cram like the two that just seemed like
a dumb idea
yeah they and vampirist had a lot of
good tales in it
yeah you know stories that it i have to
reread the trilogy one of these days i
mean i remember
i read all three books and i remember um
liking interview with the vampire the
best out of all the books
but um i don't know yeah the movie was
good like you know
i it's one of the better vampire movies
but i just always have like a [ __ ]
soft spot in my heart for the hunger
which is it's
a little bit of a weird they're not
traditional vampires she doesn't have
fangs
yeah but she's immortal and she like she
just like slices your
they can walk around during the day too
that's right i mean here's the deal
do you consider blade one and two
vampire movies
yeah i liked those movies i don't really
consider to be vampire movies too much
though because
they're very action oriented so they
don't have the same
then you can say like from dusk till
dawn right that's a vampire i'm not
really into that
okay and that's also kind of a thing
yeah
best vampire movie what i would consider
to be a real vampire movie would have
been
bram stoker's dracula yeah the acting
sucks in it
well not everyone's acting sucks just
some of the people whose names we will
not mention
and then um the original bella lugosi
[ __ ] uh dracula i liked a lot of the
hammer ones too
um honestly yeah some of those yeah the
boob fest ones were good the boob best
ones
yeah looking right well i mean like the
original ones with [ __ ] peter cushing
and
christopher lee and she said can't go
wrong with those i think at some point
in my life i've seen probably every
hammer movie ever
the thing is about things about the
original
um bellagosi one not a lot happens in it
true a lot of dialogue yeah um
well it was a stage play yeah but the
scenes with bella man are [ __ ] great
you know well like i said there's a
reason that when people like
mimic a vampire they still do his voice
yeah it's hard
hard to top that yeah it really come
here
[Laughter]
come here that's looking great yeah
he said that there's some line i don't
remember exactly what it was or
something along the lines is that
my power is that you do not believe oh
yeah you were talking about that the
other night when we were like uh
yeah yeah vampire's powers that people
don't believe in him
that's a good [ __ ] way of thinking
about it because then you don't look for
it
and you don't [ __ ] try to hunt down a
coffin because people don't believe in
that [ __ ]
even though like nowadays you saw
somebody with two marks on their neck
just like
yeah obviously it's just kind of like
just kind of like movies where it's
zombies it's like duh it's clearly
zombies can we like stop pretending that
like we don't know what zombies are
another another weird one was the
nosferatu one the one with uh uh
what's his name uh clint kinski yeah
what's his name klaus kenski yeah
yeah that was pretty interesting i liked
that one i did as well it's weird but
it's like
yeah i liked what they did with it yeah
that was pretty weird the nosferatu
remake wait i think we did a review of
that
salem's lot was great yeah sam's lots
good good vampire movie
um a lot of dialogue in it a lot of
atmospherics
the the story has to build up a lot in
it
that story kind of takes his time and i
like that i like the vampire even though
the yeah
look to kick out mr barlow his name is
the only problem with it is that mr
barlow doesn't speak
i don't remember him saying a word see i
think that it's better that he doesn't
in the book he spoke i know he did yeah
but i think it was a good choice to like
make because he had the
you know he had his like little henchmen
yeah and that guy talked
yeah played by the way he looked was
perfect that skinny [ __ ] scarecrow
[ __ ] with that face
i know he's one of my favorite screen
vampires
i mean that was a really good vampire
when he comes through the window like
somebody threw a balled up bag
of rags in there then he hits the ground
and unfolds and [ __ ] hits a man
i love that scene i love that so much
that is so [ __ ] cool
yeah it's pretty cool leslie russell
says the jack palance dracula is one of
the best
that is actually very good and we i
watched that not too long ago because i
think
i don't remember if it's shutter that
has it or if it's on
2b i kind of feel like shutter added it
and i watched it
because i hadn't i like the frankly
angela one too which
somebody sent me recently might have
been louie or i can't remember who said
it
yeah tina's talking about the scene of
the boy scratching at the window that
freaked me out when i was a kid
that freaked everybody out and then
there's another scene where i don't
remember if it was that time or another
time because i think he comes to the
window more than once if i remember
correctly they open the windows open up
i don't remember if he dreamed it or if
it really did happen the windows open up
he comes floating in
yeah and then just lands on the ground
all [ __ ] gently remember that and
then backs back out of the
the windows it was creepy that is creepy
he was on a damn
you know he was on a a crane but you
couldn't see it it looked great
movie magic yeah it looked good i mean
yeah he's gonna let me in
let me in yeah because you gotta invite
the thing
yeah that's what you got to do that's a
good one yeah
definitely all right so uh what are we
gonna
actually tomorrow we'll probably do
another movie review i actually watched
a um
a polish slasher movie on netflix
that we might review tomorrow yeah
unless we watch something else tonight
but
yeah we'll see how it goes all right so
check out blood vessel on there people
that's a good one real good give it five
stars
and uh if you haven't seen saturn's
salem's lot see that one after that one
takes a long while everyone takes a
while that one's a commitment that's a
good one that's a real good one
yeah i love salem as well yeah real good
all right so uh we'll be back again
tomorrow
to talk to you guys about another movie
so thanks for dropping by
bye